hey yo we gonna watch some mortal kombat
today i
can't think of any rambo quotes so i
resort to just
rocky persona we're gonna watch the
mortal kombat 11 rambo gameplay trailer
today i'm excited for this ever since i
revealed him and
why did the gameplay trailer came out
yesterday apparently totally
missed it here's some things i
definitely want to see some things i
definitely want to see i want to see a
hunting knife
i want to see one of those you know i
don't know the name of the gun but the
[ __ ] and the bullets over there oh yeah
one of those big like mini
yeah machine guns yeah got to see
something with a bow and arrow maybe an
explosive bow and arrow mm-hmm
yeah and yeah and and the original draft
for rambo last blood and
yes we're good that's what i want more
than anything is for him to finish
somebody off by just whacking him in the
head with a copy of that script
knife bow
there it is
oh
grenade of course when i think of a
grenade
nice
oh yes yes go go
planet hollywood
hey he's got your gun yes
there it is
yes
oh there we go oh nice nice
yes
john rambo classic that guy is
very dead after that
i love that they made him like they
incorporated him
as as a hunter you know yeah all those
hunting maneuvers like i got what i
wanted got the bow and arrows got the
guns
i mean i i think we talked about it in
the reveal trail i know we talked about
him wanting to get one of those like big
kind of gatling guns yeah yeah yeah yeah
blow someone to smithereens like in
general as i think the most brutal
deaths are in the john rambo
rambo four and then rambo four is when
he does the throat rip and
i was like oh they're gonna do it so
cool yeah and with
the moral combat blood in the city yeah
all that gruesome detail
that's exactly what i wanted i felt like
i was watching my 80s rambo come to life
in the mortal kombat game that was what
was crazy about it was it really feels
brought to life a lot of the time you
put these characters these dlc
players people from movies or whatever
and throw them into mortal kombat
and they're often doing you know moves
that are in honor
of the character but you're like you
know i don't see them move like that
yeah but actually if we're watching the
rambo movies he moves really fast here
but other than moving at the speed of a
mortal kombat character this is all from
the movie all
these kind of maneuvers are all from the
movies yeah it seems like a lot of times
they don't necessarily have to do
as much to tailor these you know main
fighting moves the stuff that's not as
specific as the fatalities or whatever
to
the actual content because you know it's
like an add-on but it does seem
here like they really took advantage of
every possibility at least you know
within the realm of
a one-on-one fighting match yeah i loved
seeing those different traps the way
that his fatality even
incorporates that like it's so gruesome
but yeah it is perfectly
tailored to him and i hope that this
signifies that you know the more and
more
movie characters they bring in the more
special they will make those because i
think that'll just serve to make these
dlc characters that much more
you know exciting for people is when
they really feel like yes i get to have
that nerd matchup of rampo and yeah the
t800 you know like that was super fun to
watch well it was also cool to see that
they changed up ramos outfits a lot from
the different movies you see some of the
actual first blood outfit in there the
main style that we're seeing him go with
like there's two from first blood i
believe and then you know the main one
that we're going with is from like the
later renditions
now we're going to get the last blood
clothing in there yeah which is just
normal stallone with a cowboy hat all
right guys mortal kombat 11 rambo are
you excited from that i think this looks
awesome this looks great it really does
feel like the
the character from the movies planted in
here well subscribe
click the notification bell hit the like
button if you enjoyed our video
blah blah blah youtuber things are you
saying outros we'll see you guys soon